[Music]
oh okay i know what i want to talk about
um you ready this is what we're going to
talk about uh super bowl commercials
okay i'll be honest didn't pay attention
to a single one of them
nope i was one that i saw and it was
with
uh amy schumer yes as the mayonnaise
commercial yes
and um never has there been a more
perfect spokesperson
for anything it's good casting that's
great it's pretty good casting
who's more mayo queen than amy schumer i
don't think there is one was that what
she was playing
he was like the male queen yeah i think
so she looked like the flight attendant
of mayo
anyway uh but no we have a few of the uh
we have a few of these commercials
apparently they were like trending mark
was saying that there's a few of these
that like
made a big splash online and uh so we
just wanted to go over a few of them
this is the first one that we just saw
we'll play against you guys could see
and this is oatley oatley is the uh
this is the uh yeah it's oat milk
company yeah and it's blown the [__] up
and i use oatley i buy oatley and um
we'll see if this commercial will uh
you know stop that
no cow no no
no wow wow
no cow
[Music]
no cow no no
no wow that's it right
this is brilliant it's so good this is
brilliant it's so good it's absolutely
brilliant i mean like
it's brilliant the point of a commercial
is what gets people talking about it
yeah yes you pay attention
okay how do you stand out
yes amongst commercials
that have budgets the size of a film
right people are going to spend millions
of dollars on a super bowl commercial
and
in the year of corona everybody's going
to be making it dramatic and we stuck
together
awful and all this [__] yes music
uh so how do you stand out you have to
be different right how do you be unique
you have to be different
different from high budget commercial
is low budget commercial 100 you want
people going how the [__]
did they just there's one camera i think
they just do
push-ins yeah one game no money on it
literally one it could be an iphone
one camera in lane they're in a field he
brought a
fake piano an electric piano he's
playing it he's the ceo i don't know if
he is the ceo
is that really the guy it says it's him
but is that really the guy yeah i mean
this is just [__] brilliant
so they spent their entire budget on
paying the nfl or cbs or whatever for
the commercial
and said we're going to spend nothing on
the commercial itself everybody knows
what the [__] it is oat milk
yeah i think when you do an um a
commercial in the super bowl
it's more it's the same way that of like
having a flagship store
right it's like if you're prada you need
to have a store on fifth avenue
because that's where the fancy stores
are and if you want to be a fancy brand
you got to be on the fancy brand street
yeah
and i think that when brands advertising
the super bowl they're not going oh
we're going to create an ad that's going
to make people
need this yeah they're really cementing
themselves
as a legitimate brand yeah right
oatley is now up there with pepsi
coke is up there with these major
beverage brands yep
right that are advertising in the super
bowl and it's not
that annoying it's kind of annoying but
also pretty fun but we know that they're
having a sense of humor about it yeah
like if you're annoyed by this
commercial
they're making fun of you yeah it's true
you're the idiot he just wasted 15
seconds of our time
every commercial in the super bowl is
supposed to be genius right it's
brilliant it's a story it's a lab rip
and he's just like wow no cow i'm going
to actually even
find over and over again yeah absolutely
ah it's just brilliant that's the best
thing about this commercial
it was filmed in 2014. no wow
the company is a swedish company and the
swedish
dairy industry sued them back then as
like an attack on the dairy industry
amazing
commercial i mean they spent you know
what's typical five million dollars
to play it yeah but yeah you know what's
interesting in an effort to save cows
they're going to kill so many human
beings that work at dairy farms
like way more humans are gonna die than
cows did i mean it sucks being a dairy
cow
yeah where they just like knock you up
and then just squeeze on your tits all
day long is what you're built to do
yeah um yeah i guess it's just being
like
latin
[__] enthusiasm when we find out how
healthy human breast milk is
latin women gotta watch out you gotta
watch
a product let's out bring back the cages
but in all seriousness uh it is it is a
[__] genius
it's the best that i've seen first of
all in years yes waste our time
make us angry make us talk about it
we're not gonna drink more or less oat
milk we're not gonna drink more or less
of anything because of super bowl ad
all you're doing is cementing yourself
as a legit company so now you gotta
stand out
[__] ballsy this is also the first
commercial of oatley i've ever seen
maybe we don't watch a lot of tv anymore
socials but now i'm like
this is the first time you've now it's
more in my mind because it's the first
commercial you've had
pepsi had thousands of ads before they
started advertising yeah so you knew
pepsi yeah hopefully people are going to
be like oh that's a little more in my
consciousness than it was before
also i judge starbucks for not having
oat milk i guarantee you they have oat
milk now oh they finish
they finna that is a branding you're
always behind the curve starbucks
[__] starbucks dog [__]
dorks try to share my namesake ho the
whole ass [__] trying to share
my name oh word
hogwarts schultz [__] [__] [__]
i want to run on a unity platform
[Music]
nah i like it i [__] with oat milk and i
think he's in every starbucks after this
and that is worth it probably oh god
this guy won
imagine the purchase of that commercial
i think they were going for like the
budweiser where they go bud wiser oh
yeah
everybody's going to hold up only be
like wow no
how much of advertising you think now is
built on the social media reaction
so much i think that's what they hope
for right like
like when i was watching the weekend's
performance last night right i was like
oh it's just trash and then i saw people
memeing yeah yeah and i was like uh he
won he won yeah the performance was
garbage
he's a garbage performer beautiful voice
incredible voice but he can't really do
anything
he can't dance and they can't put all
these dancers around him because
obviously coveted restrictions that are
probably limiting that right yeah those
dancers
he had back up there they were like in
the background though spaced apart yeah
i should've mad clever though they put
them all in the [__] masks
in like the [__] nose oh but they
were actually wearing masks
how did they dance with that bro i would
have passed the [__] out i run three
minutes on a treadmill with a mask
huffing and puffing dude that's
brilliant
yeah kind of clever oh i thought that
they were just referencing which they
obviously were like his whole life
what is it called plastic surgery thing
right yeah oh that's genius i didn't
know that they were mass because of it
but yeah that's the game now it's how do
i make this a social thing how do i make
it memeable
you know what else helps the ceo's in
good shape and that's their whole thing
is like
dairy milk is bad for you oat milk is
better for you yeah if you had some fat
[__] as a ceo
good point and it was seven years ago so
he's probably not in nearly as good of
shape now oh yeah
but he looked like american psycho back
there no killing it he was ready to do
it
okay what else we got um what's the next
one oh this is our hellman's one right
this is the mayo
i don't remember seeing this one yeah
sad
this is sad who are you i'm your fairy
godmayo
and that is a hot mess i don't know what
to do with any of this stuff
i got half an onion an artichoke what
even is an artichoke no one knows just
move over
and watch the wings now here's the
hellman's magic
creamy dreamy
oh yeah that's normal what else can you
do
absolutely nothing like nothing
you know
[Laughter]
i'm weird bro what what you liked it
i thought she was good in it she's kind
of good actress
yeah but there was nothing you know what
bothered me is all the food that she
created
none of it is good with mayo there was
yeah it was like cake there was nachos
yellow
[__] what are you doing yeah that's a
great point i also don't like amy
schumer
but she just made all the food she likes
to eat up here
yeah yeah none of it was male-based food
yeah it also wasn't funny yeah it wasn't
funny if you get a comedian you're like
yeah
get a comedian and it's directed by
peter farrelly who did dumb and dumber
brothers
yeah oh my god yeah you got that guy to
direct this the dumbbells
if you were to look up they never
advertised but if you go and look up the
directors of these spots
biggest people famous and what is that
is that just like a check for them or
like
checking between jobs these the top
movie directors will make
anywhere from thirty five thousand fifty
thousand dollars per day
to do it and some like big names just
just they know how to
do commercials well he doesn't he needs
his brother i guess
one fairly in enough but think about it
that is interesting
that you could knock out that in one day
a movie is going to take you
six months oh yeah it's gonna take you a
few minutes to shoot it and then you've
got to
edit it color corrector it's a year and
a half
oh really for the director you're
talking at least
three months of pre-product or two
months of pre-production but
all the develop once the director signs
on they're spending months
just reworking the script then you start
pre-production
then you're how much do you get three
months as a big director when you get
paid
as a big director i mean the the thirty
fifty thousand a day probably same or no
in the movie business
no no if big directors can make a few
million to
getting a piece of the back end so like
you know
todd phillips but this is like a this is
like a corporate gig for a comic
yeah like i got to be clean and it's
going to kind of suck but they're going
to tell me a big check let's just knock
it out it's work
yeah they're all signed to big but
that's the thing if you're a comic and
you sign on to commercial you gotta make
sure that [__] is funny bro yeah
yeah you really gotta do that because
you could look a little foolish
she mailed it in probably you're
probably just like who cares i guess it
was fine all right next commercial what
else we got
yeah this one got blow back because it's
rob
i don't want to like it because it's
robin hood oh yeah rip yeah don't use
that dog to manipulate what's crazy is i
think they made it before
all this [__] had to offer yeah so it's
like i couldn't imagine being on their
team being like yeah we have a super
bowl spot coming out
[__] yeah this is a commercial
don't think you're an investor we make
investments morning
noon and wait what time is it exactly
do we make short-term investments
long-term investments we diversify our
interests
realize our gains and losses and try to
keep the big picture in mind
you don't need to become an investor you
were born one
robin hood it's a good commercial
bro no you know these guys are liars
when they show black people line dancing
you can't trust that company at all
simply because of that you saw the two
black people with cowboy boots line
dancing in an open bar
yeah and then the white people that were
in that bar that looked like the same
bar
weren't disgusted like those cowboys
that were at the bar were just having
their own conversation
and then like taking their hats off and
going what the [__] is going on over
here
no that is unbelievable you didn't like
it i mean it's like
it's just shitty that they're like yeah
anyone can invest unless we say you
can't anymore because we're going to
shut off
that's how you make too much money yeah
yeah won't allow these things
but you're going to see how [__]
fraudulent it is in the face of
everything that just happened
objectively i thought it was a good
commercial if you take out the context
with context [__] them
but if you're being purely objective
feel good commercial oh we are
investors emotionally physically
whatever we all invest that's the idea
but also we know who they are so we're
like [__] you immediately when i saw
robin hood i was like i don't want to
like this [__] using a dog to make me
make me like you [__] you yeah that's
just mad effective i want a dog let me
buy dogecoin you like dogs so much
all right play this one this is uh okay
here we go
oh this is brought to you by ubereats
hey everyone welcome to waynesboro party
on wayne
party on guard as a local access show we
want everyone to support local
restaurants
but we never manipulate you the way all
these other commercials do
oh god sure that's really sad
totally we're better than that yeah
we'd never shamelessly rely on a
celebrity cameo
right cardi b yeah eat loco
or jump on the latest trend
[Music]
that was so sad right i still flame bro
i don't know what
i'm talking about y'all didn't like that
commercial i couldn't handle it man they
looked too old bruh
they do look weird they do look a little
bit weird they want some work done
hit all the nostalgia with the currents
like you don't know [__] about wayne's
world it's it's sad watching cardi b go
this corporate
i love cardi because she was cardi and
she didn't give a [__] and she got rich
doing that
now she's like a [__] democratic
spokesperson and
uber like you look stop bring back old
cardi i missed the old cardi
i missed the old card this one right
here was so dumb this might be the worst
one this is
almost as forced as we're more forced in
wayne's world maybe but the same feeling
i got this is the worst one a day over
yeah did you steal my cheetos again
just tell him it was you but i caught
you at the counter
oh
for some reason ashton thought to do
half a jamaican accent
ashton right it's ashton kutcher emil
kunis anybody who's listening and this
is the one about the cheetos okay
and shaggy's in the [__] commercial
and ashton is singing it wasn't me
but using the cheetos as the uh
i got the example or whatever it is i
don't know um
i don't know what the [__] is wrong with
him where he's doing half the jamaican
accent keep playing
he's have ash and half ash done
but i caught you at the counter wasn't
me
[Music]
saw you snacking on the sofa it wasn't
me
[Music]
[Laughter]
this is how you say shower shower yeah
you even had them in the shower it
wasn't me
why is she fully dressed in the shower
that doesn't make any sense either she
should be in her shower gear
let's shower yeah
or at least in a towel or something like
that like you're just eating
cheetos in a little black dress with
full face makeup
this doesn't make any sense keep going
she look old
[Music]
it better if she asks where they are you
say forget to never admit to a word and
please don't upset her and if she keep
on snarking i guess you will attack
well did you
wasn't me
pause okay
simp [__] simp ash it is
she's got the cheetos on her goddamn
lips her fingers
you're not eating them someone's got to
be eating that he's getting cucked out
bro he's getting [__] cut
out by cheshire he's in a [__] robe
he was clearly smashing out mila
he's just sitting there and taking it
yeah bro he goes also
you got to change your haircut dude you
can't have the same haircut that you had
when you were
famous you got to change the haircut
this is breaking my heart dude
i used to love ashton he was the [__] he
was the [__]
what happened i don't know this is the
first time i looked at him like yo this
head
come on this could have been funny maybe
if he was it wasn't me
oh yes then he can't [__] up it wasn't
me and then he's how we know him to be
funny
yeah like kind of a [__] up well it
wasn't me yeah but now he looks like
some house husband going around
cleaning up after his wife yeah trying
to sing going way too slow
mad off tempo jamaican indians
yo come on bro that's embarrassing now
do you think that it was like a woke
thing
to have him be the yeah yeah yeah
because they're like oh we don't want to
reinforce the gender role of a nagging
wife and a
disheveled husband or they may be
thought to be around the house maybe
they thought it would be funnier to do
it the other way
no it's never funnier they're like oh if
we never invert the rules girl
ghostbusters is not funnier girl ocean's
eleven is not funnier or they heard
ashton's jamaican accent and it was like
okay he has to do it [__] you
might be right we're talking about it
what if ashton was like yo dude i'm not
going to say something to jamaican
accent they're like listen podcasts are
going to make fun of you like this
for the next two weeks it's gonna be the
biggest commercial please sing as
cringe-worthy as possible
you